what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we've been covering a lot of
Marvel stuff recently of course it is
the same thing with like DC right like
we cover the new 52 Batman run and then
Wonder Woman came out so then we covered
Wonder Woman for a week so there are
like two weeks or so we was only ever
really DC content this last week about
week and a half or so it's largely been
Spider Man of course I mean it's
spider-man
what youtuber in their right mind would
not upload spider-man content the week
this Spider Man comes out but we're
finding back into the habit of reporting
more DC stuff and so what we're doing
here is we're picking up with a
continuation of Sinestro Corps award now
for those of you guys who were just
joining us if you stumbled across this
video or if just kind of piqued your
fancy or hopefully the title was quick
beta enough for you to watch it
symmetric or war was basically the first
stage in this Grand Green Lantern epic
by Geoff Johns and this is probably one
of the most important stories during his
ten-year run on the Green Lantern mythos
because this basically sets the stage
for blackest night and the war of the 7
Lantern course when in the last video we
had talked about how Sinestro a former
Green Lantern who had basically been
cast out due to the fact that he used
his Green Lantern superhero powers for
the purpose of making himself a dictator
it had gone back and basically formed
his own Lantern Corps called the
Sinestro Corps and the idea here is that
where the Green Lantern's derive their
power from willpower which is to say as
long as there are individuals out there
that have the ability to overcome fear
who can meet their challenges head-on
and face them then the Green Lantern's
will always have their source of energy
because they derive their powers from
the emotional spectrum from the
willpower element of it with a Sinestro
Corps it's almost the exact same way
except it's fear and so so long as there
are people in the universe that are
afraid of something they're terrified
for their lives there will always be
power going to the Sinestro Corps the
difference here is that the Sinestro
Corps basically their rings were able to
kill people it was just one of the
things to instill fear what better way
to terrorize an entire civilization did
it just start killing people left and
right one of the other things that we
had learned is that in order to continue
as campaign of instilling fear across
the universe that Sinestro had enlisted
some of the most powerful and some of
the most fear inducing beings to have
ever existed in the history of DC Comics
superboy-prime being one of them
basically a Superman from an alternate
universe that had no weakness with the
exception of a red Sun and magic the
anti-monitor the anti monitors basically
this Harbinger for the multiverses
destruction the same thing with cyborg
superman who had single-handedly led a
campaign that almost saw him taking over
the world following the death of
Superman in 1992
you know these characters and others who
are joined there as well basically serve
the purpose of instilling fear across
the universe and continuing to power the
Sinestro Corps rings now with regards to
Kyle Rayner
and the concept of ion Kyle Rayner was
basically a host for the entity that
represents willpower if all the energy
in the universe or if all the emotion of
will can coalesce into a single thing
that it has to be represented by
something so that one thing is basically
this giant whale and the idea here was
that Kyle Rayner would become the host
of the real power entity so that if the
Green Lantern's were ever destroyed and
if the guardians of the universe were
ever killed the Kyle Rayner could
basically resurrect them the idea of
Sinestro taking Kyle Rayner and then
removing the the willpower entity of ion
from him and replacing it with the
entity of fear in the form of parallax
was really more to like demoralize the
Green Lantern Corps I think to basically
take the greatest of them and then have
that person fall and become the very
villain that their motor the most
terrified of and so what this story does
is we start to get back into this is it
basically picks up with a character by
the name of sodam yacht now this is kind
of cool because his character is really
introduced to basically show us how bad
things are getting for the superhero
community and a lot of this really deals
with the idea of a kind of cybernetic a
sentient planet called rank and ranks is
basically this character that has
appeared over the course of DC's
publication history something like 10 or
20 times it was never a prominent thing
and the idea here was that ranks is
basically a planet that served the
purpose of kind of being a place for
villains and different folks to show up
in the idea was it eventually it led to
a conflict between Guy Gardner one of
the Green Lantern's of Earth and ranks
itself which saw ranks defeated and so
what this did is it Segway directly into
Sinestro Corps war in the sense that
ranks basically allied itself with
Sinestro if for no other reason than to
see Guy Gardner and the Green Lantern's
defeated now the reason why this matters
is because of the fact that the Green
Lantern's themselves have mow go and mow
go as crazy as it sounds is just a giant
planet with a Green Lantern ring and I
know it sounds kind of crazy but mojo is
insanely powerful because the abilities
of a Green Lantern are directly
proportional to the mass of that Green
Lantern to how strong their willpower
is the energy they can muster and so on
and so forth and so a person like how
Jordan for example wouldn't be as
powerful as someone like moe go because
Moe go is basically a planet with the
power of willpower just being blown in
any one particular direction and so for
the most part Mogo could obliterate
virtually anything in its path but the
reason why this is important is because
of the fact that Moe goes basically the
forward operating base in a lot of ways
for the Green Lantern's in the sense
that where the Green Lantern's home base
is OA proper basically the home of the
guardians of the universe
Mogo serves as a way for them to just
kind of travel around for them to peruse
the area to keep their sectors so on and
so forth but he's also a very powerful
ally and with ranks being allied with a
Sinestro Corps this basically leads to
the two of them coming into the REC
conflict now the reason why this is
important is because while moto can use
its power to totally obliterate ranks
there's also other Green Lantern's in
the vicinity and so really it would just
kind of result in collateral damage and
so what is up happening here is we
actually have sodam yacht alongside a
handful of other Green Lantern's make
their way on to ranks now the thing
about soda yacht and we'll get into him
here in a second he's really kind of
introduced as this question of what
would happen if Superman got a Lantern
ring a Green Lantern ring that's really
the idea here because remember all of
this is really hitting home to the
notion of like the members of the
Justice League getting in their own
Lantern rings this massive war between
all these different Lantern cores and so
once ranks is basically defeated by
having its central core over overloaded
which results in its explosion so Don
the audit of course revealed to have
survived the whole experience only for
Hal Jordan to chime in with the other
Green Lantern's and say the target of
Sinestro is not oh as they believed it
was instead it's the planet Earth and so
what this does is it picks up with
superboy-prime now the funny thing about
this when it comes to super warp on
we're kind of backtracking a little bit
here the superboy-prime one-shot sort of
coincide with this part of the Sinestro
Corps war but where it fits in is really
kind of up to us and it really it just
kind of comes almost immediately after
this one particular comic that we're
going to be going through here in a
second and of course you know I'll
mention as we as we pass by where it is
that it goes in but the arrival of the
Sinestro Corps really is just like this
absolute state of pandemonium for the
planet Earth because remember despite
all these different superheroes that are
there you know Superman and Batman and
so on and so forth they didn't really
know everything that was going on with
Sinestro that's one of the big things
that we had talked about in the first
part of Sinestro
war about how they were in the middle of
a conflict and then seemingly out of
nowhere
that man was met with a yellow lantern
rain it said Bruce Wayne you have the
power to instill great fear after which
the rain abandoned him because it since
the fact that Bruce Wayne had used the
Green Lantern ring at some point in time
and considered him to be tainted but
despite this one little occurrence the
Justice League didn't know everything
that was going on out there in the
universe and so the arrival of all these
Manhunter robots under the command of
cyborg superman all these different
members of the Sinestro Corps heralds
just this massive invasion of planet
Earth now keep in mind these aren't
weaklings you know Power Girl basically
this alternate reality version of
Supergirl Supergirl herself from the
main DC Universe Superman Batman's to
one and so forth they're all able to
basically use their abilities to stem
the tide of this conflict but there's so
much happening and they can only be in
so many places at once
and so one of the things that actually
ends up happening here is we have Hal
Jordan tracking down and chasing down
Kyle Rayner because remember at this
point in time Kyle Rayner is basically
the host for the parallax entity he's
literally walking fear and so because of
this warehouse worden is able to track
him down and is able to grab him
ultimately parallax absorbs Hal Jordan
as well and so again this creates for a
pretty dangerous situation just because
of the fact that keep in mind how Jordan
had declared himself to be parallax way
back in the 1990s during the events of
Emerald Twilight and so in this story
when they're referencing things about
how Hal Jordan betrayed them and so on
and so forth it was the idea that Hal
Jordan had become the host for the
parallax entity before and so with
parallax basically possessing both Kyle
Rayner and Hal Jordan two of their best
Green Lantern's are now off the table
not only that all the experience and all
the knowledge that goes with them is
absorbed by parallax as well and so it
means that parallax now knows how to
counter all these different Green
Lantern's now of course again this
really kind of like this massive arrival
of all these heroes because in addition
to the Justice League facing off against
these ancillary members of the of the
Sinestro Corps they're also forced to
face off against superboy-prime and it's
absolutely amazing the way this happens
jumping into parallax himself it gives
us a little bit of insight as to what
happens when a person is possessed by
parallax and so for Kyle Rayner he's
kind of in this world of darkness and as
is depicted it really seems to be more
of like a psychological mind State meal
more so than anything else but the fact
remains here that was house were being
absorbed as well the two of them are
basically able to use
willpower and overcome parallax and
again that's the weakness of the
Sinestro Corps is the fact that if
anybody has to fish at willpower they
can overcome this Sinestro Corps they
can overcome the yellow lantern ring and
return to their normal cells and of
course with Hal Jordan and Kyle Rayner
working together they're essentially
freed of the parallax entity now of
course a parallax intended to basically
consume or you know possibly destroy
them both it just meets with the arrival
of a ganthet and sayd a couple of the
guardians of the universe who of course
grab or end up taking Elementor I guess
really kind of splitting up hair lots
and then dispersing him among these
different lanterns which of course means
that now parallax is effectively held
prisoner instead of this being in one
central place he just kind of spread
around different lanterns so it's really
just a way to kind of remove him from
the landscape temporarily and allow the
story to focus on everything else that's
going on so again you know kind of
transitioning back to this major battle
to this major conflict we also end up
joining up with sodam yacht himself and
again the idea is that once everybody
realizes what's going on with regards to
Sinestro targeting earth this is when
they also begin to realize about the
return of the anti-monitor now a lot of
people knew about that but not everybody
did and the return of the anti-monitor
is huge because we're talking about a
level of power that's near godhood if
not on the same level
BNT monitors virtually unstoppable just
completely indestructible the yellow
Lantern Corps I guess the yellow lantern
ring doesn't really do much for
anti-monitor really anti-monitor just
kind of exists for the purpose of
fueling the fear of Sinestro which
allowed him to create his own yellow
Lantern Corps in the first place but
really I mean if you were to give you
know the anti-monitor a yellow Lantern
ring it wouldn't make any difference it
wouldn't matter I mean he'd still have
an insane amount of power it might
complement those abilities but given the
power that he has he doesn't need a
yellow Lantern ring it's kind of what
I'm hitting home at here and so with him
being on the scene the Green Lantern's
also begin to realize just how dangerous
everything is but this is when we cue
into the arrival of sodam yacht and
sodam yacht kind of pops up on the scene
and basically becomes the new house for
the entity of willpower for ion now the
reason why this is so significant and
the reason why this is so big it's
because this leads us directly into the
whole idea of the prophecy of blackest
night with regards to the I guess the
one shot of superboy-prime
fitting in between these two little
segments here we basically pick up after
superboy-prime it fought and wrecked all
these different superheroes and the idea
it's at superboy-prime facing off
against sodium yot it's kind of
complemented by soda I'm talking about
the whole event running it over in his
mind and commentating and so on and so
forth but it also gives us a little bit
of insight into his character and what
happens here is DC basically goes back
and grabs the idea of a place called
dachshund now Jackson was basically a
planet that was introduced in 1963 and
Action Comics number 312 I'm not going
to swear to that though but it was
created by a guy named Edmund Hamilton
and Emin hamilton had found his claim to
fame in science fiction novels and so he
was very big on writing stories that
dealt with spacefaring adventures and
things like that because of the fact
that that sci-fi had overtaken the
popularity of comics of superheroes in
the 1950s it made sense that if DC was
trying to re instigate her trying to
reinitiate this second renaissance of
superheroes in the 1960s but they would
in turn grab science fiction writers to
pull it off and so dachshund was
introduced essentially as a planet that
was colonized by a group of Kryptonians
that had broken away from Krypton proper
as to what this did is it introduced the
idea that there could be another
Superman out there if he was exposed to
a Yellow Sun now the origin that was
originally given given to us in 1963 was
a little bit different the one that I
just kind of ran over it's basically the
one that we get in this particular story
but notice this conflict between
superboy-prime and sodam yacht's despite
the vast power that sodam has he's
basically channeling willpower in its
most pure form he's not like a Green
Lantern using his ring to access
willpower he is willpower he's getting
totally obliterated by superboy-prime
it's almost not even a conflict here
it's almost not even a battle it's just
absolute destruction on an incredible
scale not only that we also sort of
harken back to this origin story of soda
which is actually really really amazing
and again it really focuses on this idea
that over the course of their existence
áand Aksum the the inhabitants as they
call themselves maximized eventually
became afraid of anything that didn't
hail from their planet as the result is
that they became extremely isolated from
the rest of the universe and never
really traveled outside their own planet
now the idea of sodam as he existed was
that he was a kid who basically looked
to the stars always wanted the idea to
achieve something greater and so the
overall goal here is it eventually he's
met by an alien that crash lands on the
planet the two of them began to talk and
sort of you know exchange ideas and
learn what the others used to only for
Soto's actions to be discovered by his
parents and
for this alien to basically be taken and
to be killed and then used as propaganda
at the same time so ins mind is just
kind of wiped or at least modified
forcing him to come to the belief that
the arrival of an alien would simply be
the herald of destruction for their
planet again more or less brain
Washington's going on here but where his
parents had hoped that Sodom yalla
basically abandoned the idea of looking
to the stars you know wanting to move
beyond their planet and focus strictly
on the role that his race was supposed
to play instead he basically said no and
it instilled in him an increasing fire
to get outside of their world and to go
see what was out there but where he had
finished building the ship it's
basically coincided with the arrival of
a Green Lantern ring because of his
willpower because of his ability to
overcome fear fear of the unknown
ultimately it led to him becoming a
Green Lantern himself now again the
reason why this is important is because
he has Kryptonian heritage and that's
one of the things that he talks about as
he's commenting on this fight with a
superboy-prime he starts to talk about
the idea of you know when he was
basically met by the guardians of the
universe they said look you are part
Kryptonian when you're exposed to the
Yellow Sun radiation of Earth's Sun
you're going to start getting powers but
this is kind of cool because he doesn't
have the ability to learn how to use
those powers I mean if he if he was in
the middle of a fight for his life
against superboy-prime sure Superman
could sit him down and teach him hand it
how to use the various ability that he
has but he's basically learning what
he's able to do as he's fighting the
problem with this is that he's facing
off against superboy-prime at
superboy-prime has a wealth of
experience under his belt he fought
during crisis on Infinite Earths which
means that superboy-prime had faced off
against the anti-monitor superboy-prime
it helps you would instigate all the
events of Infinite Crisis and is fought
and defeated the entirety of Earth's
superhero roster on two separate
occasions this is not some kid who's
just kind of running amuck and being
angsty this is a kid that's got all
kinds of problems but he's also
battle-hardened and so that's what makes
this so cool is because despite the fact
that sodam yot does everything he can to
try to face off against superboy-prime
in the end there's nothing he can do he
just cannot hold his own the other
reason why sodam yot is so important is
because it actually sort of transitions
to this extra layer of this discussion
that takes place between ganthet and
sayd and the Earth's Green Lantern's
which is to say Hal Jordan Jon Stewart
guy Gardner and Kyle Rayner
and what is up happening here is Gant
didn't say basically reveal the idea of
the prophecy of the blackest night and
this is why sodam yacht was so important
because if sodam yacht were to be killed
by superboy-prime it would fulfill the
first stage of the prophecy now the
prophecy of blackest night isn't
necessarily the prophecy of the Black
Lantern range at least as it's given
here the prophecy of blackest night is
the idea that there will basically be a
rise of six new Lantern cores in
addition to the Green Lantern's now one
of the things is established over the
course of geoff johns run is that these
different Lantern cores some of them had
existed for thousands and thousands of
years if not millions of years others
are cropping up for the very first time
the Green Lantern's had existed since
the times like Guardian to the universe
made them you know however many
thousands of years ago with regards to
the star sapphires data existed for
quite some time as well the red lanterns
they existed for a pretty lengthy time
but when it came to the idea of the
Sinestro Corps that's still pretty near
things like the orange Lantern ring you
know that one seems pretty new the idea
of the Blue Lantern ring of Hope that
one hasn't even been made yet but the
overall prophecy is that all these
lanterns are all these Lantern cores
these seven Lantern courts will
eventually come together and they will
engage in a conflict that will
essentially lay waste to the entirety of
all emotion across the universe so the
prophecy of blackest night basically
foretells a circumstance where all
emotion across the universe will be
totally gone now in terms of what
blackest sign actually is as the story
and what the prophecy really means that
all unfolds in the actual blackest night
story itself which is amazing but the
fact remains here that in the middle of
this conflict ganthet and sayd basically
kind of bail out they're like look we're
not allied with anyone particularly your
superheroes or so on this is your fight
you guys have to go deal with it we are
essentially outcast in the guardians of
the universe we're here to help provide
guidance but not really here to fight
when it comes to you all these different
you know members of the Lantern cores
and the Sinestro Corps and the Green
Lantern Corps is facing off in the end
this entire conflict really seems to
kind of turn keel and face on the idea
of the anti-monitor of course the reason
for this is because of the fact that
with the sinestro corps members learning
that the Green Lantern can now kill
they've basically been authorized by the
guardians of the universe to start
killing Sinestro Corps members some of
them run some of them were just like we
gotta go they just bail out others died
in the conflict and some are still
fighting but the fact remains here that
what the anti-monitor himself he's the
most credible threat and the reason for
this is because of the fact that the
anti-monitor basically channels
antimatter energy and so he would be
like
your left fist was antimatter and your
right fist was positive matter and they
punched they would cancel each other out
and so the idea of the anti-monitor
unleashing all this antimatter energy is
to quite literally lay waste and
completely obliterate the universe and
then travel into the multiverse and do
the same thing and that's exactly what
the anti-monitor would do that's the
reason why the anti-monitor allied
itself with Sinestro was to be able to
achieve this goal because Sinestro
basically said look we'll clear the
landscape of superheroes and will allow
you to go do your own thing the other
half of this is that even with the
superheroes facing off against
anti-monitor as best they can they still
can't hold their own now of course with
Chi Waner being freed of parallax at Hal
Jordan being free to free to parallax
and all these different guys this
basically leads to several fights all
coinciding at the same time for example
with the idea of war world basically
this giant planet this forward operating
bases sorts that's used by Sinestro for
the purpose of allowing US forces to
muster into a single location and then
launch an attack on earth it's
essentially this massive powerhouse of
energy because on world world resides
the Sinestro Corps central power battery
basically the source of all their energy
but it's basically this massive bomb
this massive explosive device so the
idea of the Green Lantern's is to use
this to basically hit the anti-monitor
with the full brunt of all fear across
the universe and then hope to obliterate
them in the process at the same time
because of the fact that Kyle Rayner and
and Hal Jordans rings have lost their
power
owing to the fact that the Manhunter
robots have the ability to absorb green
lantern energy this also leads to all
these different things kind of winding
down and coming to a close for example
with Hank Henshaw
when this massive Warworld bomb is
dropped on the anti-monitor or at least
us hit into him the idea of hank henshaw
is that he'll finally be able to die and
that's one of the most tragic things
about this because remember when hank
henshaw
basically became cyborg superman before
the events of the death of Superman
leading into the events after the death
of Superman he was a non remorseful
being all he wanted to do was just
destroy things but the idea was that he
had basically been faced with the notion
that he had lost everything he loved and
cared about when he became cyborg
superman and so he had essentially been
on this quest to die and the idea was
that he had allied himself with the
anti-monitor and Sinestro because the
anti-monitor said when this is all done
I will kill you you will finally be
freed of your imprisonment it was kind
of an ironic thing because ultimately it
the green lanterns that seem to be
engineering the process by which savoir
Superman will die when he puts them into
the direct path of the explosion of war
world hitting the anti-monitor
and so it's really kind of a bittersweet
little thing it's actually kind of an
interesting little moment here but with
Sinestro sort of coming down with the
intention of using this Lantern ring to
take out Kyle Rayner to take out how
Jordan they in turn reprogram one of
these Manhunter robots and absorb the
yellow lantern energy of Sinestro now
this is not a great big huge thing but
what it does do is it allows for a
direct hand-to-hand fight between the
three of these guys and the reason why
this is important is because remember
Sinestro had been a longtime enemy of
Hal Jordan they had fought for years and
years and years and years but when Hal
Jordan declared himself parallax
essentially killed Sinestro only for
Sinestro basically survived the
experience to be resurrected and then in
turn become an enemy of Kyle Rayner this
is the one theme that both have in
common
Kyle Rayner and Hal Jordan have both
called Sinestro their mortal enemy and
so it's really just kind of like this
knock-down drag-out fight between the
three of them at the same time
superboy-prime is taking no prisoners I
mean it's one of the coolest things
because you've got Superman you've got
Power girl you've got all these
different superheroes who were there
doing the best they can to hold him back
and at the end of the day none of it
matters she's still able to take out
almost every last one of them because
remember you're talking about a
character who's more powerful than any
current version of Superman who's faster
than any current version of Superman
who's stronger you know he has more
endurance he has a higher level of
durability and there's no green
kryptonite and no red you know no red
Sun within the immediate vicinity he's
virtually unstoppable but the cool thing
about this is that in the middle of all
that he basically gets more than he
bargained for and the reason why is
because due to his arrogance and his
hubris one of the guardians of the
universe sets upon him and then
self-destruct and this makes sense
because remember the guardians of the
universe are insanely powerful and it
was really required for them to act
because if they hadn't stepped in and
stopped superboy-prime none of it would
have mattered superboy-prime would have
destroyed every single Green Lantern he
would have destroyed every single
superhero and there's nothing that they
could have done to stop it they'd be
virtually powerless I mean it would it
would have been the end of all things
and he almost guaranteed to kill sodam
yacht and so it would have set in motion
the death of almost everything in
existence and so what ends up happening
here is that with a battle basically
winding down geoff johns the writer of
the story begins the process
of going through and sort of bringing
all these different themes to a close
but also setting the stage for the next
set of events remember ganthet and sayd
despite the fact that they are guardians
of the universe are separate from the
rest of the guardians they've been
outcast because they one did not agree
with what the guardians were doing and
two worked against the other guardians
of the universe and so the result is
that they basically kind of go off and
they do their own thing at the same time
it's also a bit of reconciliation
between the various superheroes and the
Green Lantern's and helping humanity
sort of get past everything but it's
also the idea the superboy-prime had
basically been shunted out of the
existing universe and sent to a whole
nother universe in its entirety and so
again it almost seems like you've
basically been sent back to its home
place but the issue is that during the
events of countdown to Final Crisis I
think it is it's going to show that he's
actually been sent to a whole different
universe which is flees to a whole
another set of events but the other gist
of this is that with ganthet and sayd
looking around and realizing that in the
midst of all this that somebody's going
to basically have to have the ability to
help out the Green Lantern's to offer
themselves as kind of a support group if
it's necessary the two of them in turn
bond their energies and form the blue
lanterns the Lantern Corps of Hope and
so again this is how all this stuff
begins to build that's where Sinestro
Corps begins to wind down it's almost
like these peaks and valleys you know
you see the story starting to wind down
into a valley only for the ending to
begin winding up into a peak and we end
up finding these things out because of
the fact that the Manhunter robots
tracked down the remains of hank henshaw
and basically resurrected and it's one
of the saddest things ever because where
he believed that he was going to be free
of this life that he was going to be
dead he's instead brought back to life
he cannot ever truly died his Manhunter
robots will always keep him going but
the big jaw dropping moment in this
particular part of the story and the one
that really just kind of left people
flabbergasted was the fate of the
anti-monitor
the anti-monitor is a being that is so
incredibly powerful that he just can't
be destroyed through conventional means
it would take basically that god of the
DC Universe to present to really just
kind of destroy him in its entirety but
the idea that the anti-monitor still
resides in the realm of the
quote-unquote afterlife or at least what
passes for the afterlife in the DC
Universe and it still held in on
achieving its goal of taking over
everything only for him to be
transmogrified into this singular power
source for the Black Lantern rings
themselves but with that being said guys
we're going to go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
commerce explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the
robb cork you guys enjoyed this video
sure you drop a like and yeah Sinestro
Corps war was amazing but it only gets
better from here that's the craziest
thing I feel like it only just keeps
keeps getting better and better
especially with blackest night with
brightest day it gets pretty insane but
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]